how do you guys well you know I mean
this so this award means a lot for film
like this because this is a film that is
about urban violence in Chicago and when
we were making it I think we we never
would have anticipated the reception
that the film has gotten in the last
year and to have a common a really
culminated with this award means a lot
it means a lot for what the films about
it means a lot as independent filmmakers
I mean I've been doing this for 27 years
now so it means a lot to save everybody
could you tell me how they don't shake
up in the first
a back injury
well you know we started you that can
see fulfillment maybe a year in the life
of the city with these interruptions and
so part of the process finding that
characters is you see the film we end up
with three remarkable individuals people
were not really fun to be with
eventually expiring and so this story
into being video with these three
interrupter and they were the ones who
got us out on the streets on and it
through them that we met some of the
secondary captains of those sorcerers
that could apply to that for the
narrative
and Alex's article was the initial
inspiration for the film he wrote a
piece to the new york times magazine
that just was incredible and out tonight
that friends for many years and and so
this is a great chance to collaborate
with him but it really started to his
heart
wait my turn
Chicago's a great place to be a bit
later you know it's funny I remember
when I first went to Sundance people
would say where you from New York or LA
and and I'd say well Chicago they all
call so I think what's great about
Chicago is that the community there in
the filmmaking community particularly in
the documentary community is a very
close-knit community we we support each
other we pull for each other and and
there's just there's so many great
stories I'm a Chicago is sort of the
quintessential American city and it's
sort of i think every kind of story you
want to tell is right there and I've
done films and other flip house there's
something about filming Chicago it's all
these burgers
well I told Alex this is his first you
know documentary i calling you should
just walk away and just lady while the
goings good yeah I mean so but we want
to do films together and work together
actually in the future realm with Alex
writing me directing so that's something
we hope to do I love will do another
documentary
do you have a regular
maybe work but
yeah I I mean I've been affiliated with
car temple in films of Chicago for 27
years it's an incredible institution
they were like an iconic documentary
production company been around since
nineteen sixty-six so you know that's
the long term involve any vote for me it
goes all the way back to hoop dreams I
first walked in their door 27 years ago
and instead I'd like to do this film so
it means a lot to still be working with
them and then of course there are people
I work with as individuals off and on
over the years we always worked really
small though I mean that civil ideas to
keep it small effect for this film they
were really three of us were sort of the
man keeps keeping myself an exact type
of the co-producer so we were intent on
just
who is small I don't normally operate my
own camera but on this film it made
sense to to keep us as small as possible
so it was a gas I mean the nature of the
spell was is that we were intimately
involved in people's lives and calling
around for this period of 12 and 14
months and so it was such a I I can't
say enough what a special experience it
was because of the people were following
the work they were doing and plus they
were just a hell of a lot of quantity
around maybe they're like great people
that funny and they're alive and they
redeem themselves it alive to 10 very
profound ways we shot we shot the film
on ps3 camera card camera HD how can
people support day interrupters work
thank you i can i can people support
your work well Emil they work for this
great organization for pharmacies fire
and so they're always looking for fun
Davis's organization was founded by a
public health doctor and
and there are any one given period of
time 2250 interruptive around that table
volume dip date and it's secure most of
them are ex-cons it is the one job but
they can get and you know they've
exported the model of the interrupters
to other cities and there's other
there's other organizations in lots of
major American cities even if they're
not using a Rutgers model that are doing
important work around this issue so i
think it's great to support seastar we
also think of wherever you live there's
people trying to deal with this issue
there was support yourself
see farming I like advice of that book
right